ambiance tamisée et chaude éclairée à la
bougie musique douce
ariel savoyen apaise les mots de ses
patients cette voyageuse transmet son
savoir à travers le massage est donc à
chaque fois je me faisais ma c thaïlande
vietnam
enfin non vraiment dans beaucoup
d'endroits et à chaque fois en effet je
me faisais pas c'est parce que j'aime
vraiment ça et je me rappelle toujours
d'une fois c'est en thaïlande où je me
suis fait masser et ça remonte à je
dirais 20 ans à peu près et quand la
personne hamas et je me suis dit je
rêverais de faire ce qu'elle fait j'ai
créé l'atelier de massage en 2011
en février 2011 donc ça va bientôt faire
six ans on est à versailles celle à
versailles un échange un geste un
mouvement et une énergie
c'est ce que communique ariel sa voyante
durant ces séances avec ses mains elle
décèle chaque intention cachée plus plus
on masse plus on se rend compte des
tensions des personnes 2
dont foot est le sport qu'elles peuvent
pratiquer on peut s'en rendre compte
aussi par la musculature et puis et puis
surtout à chaque fois différents et ça
c'est super amateurs ou d'un client
régulier ariel savoillans s'adapte aux
patients et propose différents types de
massages alors vous allez massage
californien qui est le massage le plus
enveloppants et le plus facile à
recevoir je dirais qu'ils s'adaptent
vraiment au gré des besoins de la
personne
après vous et le massage ayurvédique qui
est un massage d'origine indienne qui
régule les énergies qui s'appuie sur la
médecine l'ayurveda quai lamartine
indienne via les massages balinais
fameux x massage un cinquième sens
qu'elle a développée et qui a porté ses
fruits
ariel savoyen est en train d'ouvrir un
nouveau salon à paris à découvrir en
février prochain